we're very happy to be here we're here
we're doing it hey hey guys I'm here
with Lisa Schwartz and we just recorded
a full episode of not too deep which was
a very educational yeah but not too deep
exactly uh I mean I got oh no you have
to listen to it to really understand
this make sure you go over to iTunes or
SoundCloud and listen to that episode
but right now we're gonna play yeah
we're gonna play a familiar game cards
against humanity which you may or may
not know about but we're gonna put the
youtuber twist on it yeah which is a
thing I saw Shane and Colleen did the
video like this recently and I thought
it'd be really fun
where I asked you guys on Facebook to
give me topics youtuber centric topics
that Lisa and I can pull cards from and
try and figure out what is the most fun
appropriate I guess response to those
topics and then you can title this the
youtuber cards against humanity which
will get more clicks so Internet do you
- wait right that's your TED talk and
our first YouTube topic is youtuber book
title oh so good so we're each going to
pull three cards without looking looking
okay and now from these three cards we
could choose the one that we think is
the best answer
oh oh all New York Times bestsellers
right okay this one is my entrance
between two and I feel like I'm making
the wrong choice but we're glad Vardhan
okay there you go okay the first one on
the list is farting and walking away a
very serious it's a sin J yeah that's
like what happens when I post a youtube
video it's got a good digital fart and
then I walk away from it incredible
uh this is you guys tell me whose book
this is it's entitled penis envy mmm yes
what do you guys think
promoting collectively I mean it's up to
you guys yeah yes it is a baby
what youtubers do on a Friday night
oh now like are we talking about like
most youtubers are like me okay oops
oh yeah okay yeah yeah oh this is like
this is say yeah find got real meta a
German dungeon porn so if you ever
wonder what Flula does on a Friday night
google it and this says cards against
humanity' whoa yeah - real - really
sorry
- real okay I'll let you guys decide
they're all like this won't meet
everyone just like shamefully okay the
next topic is Troye Sivan new song is
called oh this is so these aren't the
best I wish I had different options but
I want to switch options with you and
see which one of these Rick do you want
to do that yeah cuz you know which one
you would have picked yep okay we're
switching oh yeah isn't really meeting
there's no way of winning this can I
pick - yeah okay it'll be a the the
title that the radio gives the song and
then the real the radio title of the
song is go-gurt the actual real title of
the song is Rush Limbaugh's soft shitty
body
I chose David Bowie flying on a tiger
made of lightning this is art oh honey -
I'm you're all winners I feel like he's
the winner here really the audience you
win let try know which title you want
his newest song to be and spam him with
your Twitter because it's the only way
change happens
this is the newest youtube trend is the
blank challenge oh this is good okay why
is this not like a thing for choosing
YouTube challenges it's just blindly JB
it is oh oh oh
can I read my cards yes yes you can
because YouTube challenges are very
important so yeah these aren't easy
seriously those are no good
oh yes uh well whoa whoa um okay uh can
i I'm gonna use all three the new
YouTube challenge is a variation of the
ferry kill called foreskin Nazis dead
babies you just have to decide who's who
I didn't say it's gonna be like a
successful YouTube challenge a legit
challenge this feels like a feasible one
it's the invisible hand challenge
joining me like this sounds like a real
like we got to work on this would you
need this a green screen and a green
globe yeah and then like the Bonnies
delimit Lisa thank you so much for
participating of the best I mean I think
this was more or less just a
brainstorming session for us rather than
it I'll get back to you on this here
again couple weeks I make sure that you
go listen to the full podcast on iTunes
or SoundCloud not too deep with grace
Helbig and Lisa Schwartz and go check
out Lisa's channel because we shot a
video over there that will change your
life in a way I don't know domestic
goddess right yeah yeah you look
adorable uh yeah